I think this is a safest way to travel
these days
it's through geoguessr so um yeah
geoguessr time maybe we'll do a couple
rounds we'll do like a 1 minute timer
and then then I'll do like a speed run
ok so I assume we have a global audience
if you don't know what geoguessr is it's
pretty straightforward
you'll you'll see we're gonna be put in
a random spot on Google Maps and we have
to guess a location where are we in the
world so we have a minute I honestly
have no idea we have any signage totally
South Africa that's not a bad guess when
in doubt South Africa right South Africa
they drive on the left side I'm not sure
it's hard to tell which side of the road
we're driving on
hmm see what the sign says okay we got
one sign we have to guess New Zealand is
also a guess they're going South Africa
outside Kimberley
hey it's South Africa good job chats
good job chats it was closer to wherever
this is thorn bill yeah on some road
well done got the country so the max
score per round is five thousand got
thirty six hundred fifty nine okay round
two another tough location something was
telling me like maybe Eastern Europe
like Czech Republic Poland Russia I
don't know if Germany is on Google Maps
curved most of Germany Denmark is I
guess she done marks on the bad guys
definitely has European vibes
hmm just say I can't see it
yeah we're near a farm we can go let's
go Czech Republic da it was Estonia a
lot of people are saying Germany
I thought Czech Republic is like it's
close and had some of the same shrubbery
but yeah Eastern Europe mm-hmm never
been to Estonia anyone from Estonia
watching I was asking earlier like where
people are from
it was very diverse anyway um okay still
got some points sir
let's move on we have Poland Lithuania
nice Norway okay this is feeling
slightly hilly
okay let's find the gas station what is
this restricted area
so it's English Caltex I don't know what
that is this could very well be us
Yamaha yeah this feels like us but what
states there's mountains in the distance
feeling like Colorado something
let's go Colorado what it was Australia
people were guessing all these states
and faceless faceless South Australia
also Cardiff an it yeah I should have
paid attention or looked very like which
side we were driving on and got three
points I was terrible okay
lesson learned next round ooh
[Music]
okay this feels like Africa some English
Kenya is my first guess Steven is
Douglass's Kenya there's only a select
few African countries on Google Maps
I think Kenya Ghana I think Nigeria see
if there's any clues and the signs hotel
something mountains in the distance
okay let's zoom into Africa they're
mountains you tell let's go there a 230
oh is Uganda within 230 miles it's tough
when there's time pressure there's not
too much time for exploring over 4,000
points it's pretty good okay let's let's
go for the last round this is giving off
some Australian vibes just a plant life
it's very residential area how do I get
out of here
it's very clean too
[Music]
we have the mean road oh okay we're in
Denmark definitely in Denmark not sure
yeah let's just find Denmark anyone from
Denmark that wants to chime in where
this could be it's very residential
maybe closer to Copenhagen outside let's
go this place Wow Wow
one mile away haha Wow it's hard to do
better than that
oh well I guess I could not do better
oh one mile way seeing the sign that
said Denmark really helpful thanks for
the bits yeah I was I was in Copenhagen
there's actually you spent more time in
Helsingborg which is up here for a chess
tournament
so like the residential area looks kind
of familiar but yeah that's got to be
one of my best guesses ever what a game
now I feel bad about that Australia
guess I was like if it would have been
it would have been a really good game if
I didn't make that one really bad guess
okay well that was fun hope you guys
enjoyed that
yeah 5000 is a maximum score to get 5000
you have to be like I think within a
certain number of yards maybe within 20
yards okay yeah we can do another I'm
gonna I don't want to be here forever so
I'm gonna do 20 seconds this is super
speed rounds last one the goal is to
break I guess five thousand okay
oh it's alejandro where could this be
oh there's no time left man South
America maybe Bolivia Wow
got Bolivia I got Bolivia of 50 miles
away well the guess rule I mean I saw
the mountains and Bolivia has mountains
okay
it's two of my best guesses ever like
back-to-back Wow
okay this one's within 50 miles but
still okay mentally prepare myself for
next round
ooh what is this what is this okay let's
not get too fixated Oh what is this
place we're in we're in Scandinavia
maybe
let's go Norway da it was France that
was a very confusing place at least we
got Europe yeah I was there not too many
clues to go by there I've got some
points okay next round
ooh okay probably Africa motorbikes see
some language pants Imperial I'm
probably gonna go with Kenya again could
be Uganda welcome thanks for joining
appreciate it another pretty good guess
I had a similar place last time and I
think last time I also guess Kenya again
it was Uganda but still over 4,000 with
20 seconds is it's pretty good Oh your
Bolivia guess was more impressive than
in Denmark guess yeah I guess because
there is no clear sign but still Denmark
guess within one mile okay this is a
good good round good few rounds let's go
okay I see sheep I'm thinking New
Zealand the sky look New Zealand Tish
I don't know this could be Middle East
let's go New Zealand da was South Africa
or know it was it was Lesotho Lesotho is
a country that's like hugged by what's
the right word encapsulated surrounded
by South Africa that's tough what to do
landlocked there we go inside got 12
points yeah the problem is if you guess
New Zealand and it's some other country
then you're probably pretty far away
okay that was rough let's go
final round ooh like Middle East's
didn't guess Tunisia I have no idea
though Hey
it was Tunisia let's go before
okay let's karlie be one of my best like
speed runs ever Wow well the game I got
Tunisia within 144 miles so just one
really bad guess
yeah I've had Tunisia like a few times
they have very like desert erodes my
scorer this game compared to the first
one it was pretty similar the first one
was also like 15,000 something youtube
worthy yeah I don't have any geoguessr
content on YouTube I think this will
have this will probably go on YouTube
YouTube people thanks for watching let
me know if you want to see more
geoguessr content